hi I'm Matt Welch with nick gillespie
we're here on ask a libertarian day 2012
in honor of the paper bag publication of
the Declaration of Independence so next
question actually several questions from
several people but let's just name check
Angelo boo chicas via Facebook and
Matthew Bellus via Facebook what is nick
gillespie the most effective way
libertarians can affect political change
a good question I you know we need to
look at it from a multiple set of
platforms there's legal change the
libertarian legal movement which was the
subject of several reasons stories over
the past couple of years has been hugely
influential there's a public interest
law firms like the Institute for justice
that do stuff there's things like the
Cato Institute which may kind of broad
based policy recommendations there's
journalistic outfits like Reason
Foundation the publisher of Reason
magazine reason calm reason TV etc there
are ways of engaging culture to affect
social change and to change the way
people think the way they act the way
they make businesses the way they
structure all sorts of arrangements I
think we need to be doing this across
the board in all levels and you should
follow whatever you're most passionate
about it most interested in but slob
Havel of the late former president and
playwright Czechoslovakia and Czech
Republic had a way of talking about this
that always resonated with me is
celebrating those who expand the zone of
freedom and which might not necessarily
be a political act it's not an
initiative in a western state it's not
elected this or that Republican or
Democrat congressman doing something or
other it's actually just making it more
possible to talk and and make jokes
about things in the in the culture
everywhere else and I think that is a
legitimate way and we talk a lot about
that in the book of Americans who just
got tired of being constricted and what
they wanted to do whether that was
brewing home of making beer at home
which is illegal in this country until
the early 1970s and a variety of other
activities that shouldn't be illegal but
frequently are Americans by pushing and
insisting and creating bigger zones of
freedom then create knock-on effects
that help the broader culture and
eventually trickle back a default you
know I was talking with somebody not
long ago and I asked them you know who
who was the speaker of the house during
the Great Depression or during the New
Deal years we know Shirley Temple was a
huge star is Shirley Temple more
important you know then whoever the
speaker of the house was we don't have
to answer that yes or no culture matters
tremendously and as we say again and
again throughout the book politics is a
lagging indicator having the right
politicians in the right political
institutions in place is hugely
important but change does not come first
and foremost from politics it's that
lagging indicator ask a libertarian keep
coming back for more
you